let me say a few words about roger
reeves
pablo escobar and the war on drugs this
conversation with roger is unlike any
i've ever done
in the eyes of many including the law
roger is a criminal
a bad man who has added to the suffering
in the world
but he never directly engaged or
participated in the violence
unlike his bosses pablo escobar and
jorge
ochoa his crime was a transport of drugs
i thought about this and about pablo
escobar
who was at once both a brutal murderer
and a robin hood figure
who helped the poor and was loved by
thousands
if not millions we sometimes idolize
murderers
and destroy good honest men we give
power and money to corrupt politicians
and dictators that starve and murder
their own people
given this i think about what makes for
a good man
and what makes for a bad man and who
decides
sitting across from roger i saw a
complicated man
but one who has kindness in his heart a
love for money
and adventure and a disdain for violence
again his crime was the transport of
drugs since 1971 the war on drugs has
cost us
one trillion dollars marijuana
legalization alone
would save and make 13.7 billion dollars
that could send more than 650 000
students to public universities every
year
then there's the human stories of the
500 000 human beings sitting in prison
for drug-related offenses
and the 1.1 million on probation and
parole
their life is damaged or ruined beyond
repair
due to the prohibition of drugs there's
a lot more to be said
about the damage done by the war on
drugs but when reading about roger's
story
and talking to him i couldn't escape the
thought that while society wants to
label him a criminal
and a bad human being there are much
worse men out there
who we give a pass to even give power to
even men who hold political office or
run companies
i also think about my role as an
interviewer sitting across a man like
roger
in these interviews in life in many ways
i continue to be myself
a person who like dostoyevsky is the
idiot
seeks the good in all people but is hurt
by it on occasion
and maybe is destroyed by it in the end
i'm not naive but i'm also optimistic
and have hope
for humanity that's who i am and that's
what these conversations are
i hope you join me and i hope you
understand that i come from a place of
love
you